hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach now I know that it
has been quite a while since last I
played this and there have been many
updates but I didn't realize it was that
long ago that I played this because my
last part in the series was back in um
May and it is now almost October so I'm
ready to play this now there have been
quite a few updates to the game since
then
markiplier underscore expects and uh I
don't know they said they added two new
SD peas and a slew of new things to the
environment and different wiki wonky
ways things to go so I'm not exactly
sure what to expect but just opening up
in to vent that title music makes me uh
makes me nostalgic for all the horrors
that I've missed out on in all the F's
that I don't give and anti-god never
mind it I did this game was like back
way when I played it boy before I played
it like way too much it's one of the
scariest I've ever played just cuz it's
brand ibly generated and I never know
what to expect in that damn mannequin
son of a Oh
the familiar play oh oh the familiar
places horrible death and despair yeah
you're not gonna die
curse now hey buddy hey it's mild friend
173 nice ace on you nice aboot eh are
you doing doing good
hey chillax over there where'd you go
what happened
don't dick with me I just started I just
turned to the game-saver okay wait wait
a minute this room wasn't here before
this is kind of wait
this was downstairs I had to go
downstairs before oh you mean I don't
have to go down there or probably still
do but I mean whatever where are you you
right there God stop that you're not
even that close you're in floor below
okay you just settle down there sonny
jim and i'm going to go down and say hi
but you gotta stop being a son of a
okay alright okay wah wah wah wah whoa
hey buddy okay you just stay over on
that side and I'm gonna play use day all
right outside I'm gonna play where's the
door button where's the door buddy yeah
where's the damn time out I'm gonna
blink no I'm gonna blink no no where's
the door oh okay all right okay all
right okay Chris Dula where's the door
button buddy what'd you do with the door
other doors down here oh I get it
that's why they moved everything
upstairs because this is I don't need to
go down here anymore pretty good do you
hi back guy Chris I press race I forgot
a fake place okay all right I'm okay I'm
okay I'm getting horrible SCP flashbacks
okay so apparently I don't need to go
down there and I don't need to suggest
myself to that though screw you forever
and go die forever
Oh
without a body boots
stop it stop doing the Mambo shuffle in
there
that is a pole oh that's party who did
that radical Larry getting a little too
radical ah that body does not live here
that face yeah yeah all right
so scp-173 is just shuffling on down and
I'm continuing through the facilities oh
look it's dead end
I think dead end right yeah this is one
of those doors that I can't okay well
what what's the point of having a room
like that if I can't go through it but I
don't care don't care okay long-haired
okay
yo how many times I've killed myself on
one seven three was that another door
opening up did that door just open up my
dog was worth the gurgling now gurgling
you stop it this door opened up on
his own
why why why did do that why did he do
this okay what I like out of sudden
burst of speed for some reason I don't
know why someone pushing me stoned
behind me okay I don't know what new I
see Oh what happened my mouth is just my
meows just dirt what stop with the
noises my mouse just jerked to the right
for some reason I didn't do it I swear
okay okay another rum that leads to more
rooms hello what oh it's a van it's not
spitting though okay all right okay
goddamn it it's more rooms there's a
series of rums I'm gonna Lee did it oh
oh wait a min I get in here now push I
need a higher I need at least a level to
to get in there I think I thought I
could get in there with a level one
before but they must have changed that I
mean to be honest it was a bit too easy
to get higher level security cards
someone in here ah
oh this is the room where he's dancing
around in the glass room and then breaks
through because it's none of a big hi
buddy
ahh leveled oh-oh I got a love pool I
can get into the thingy and that guy can
go die forever I'm gonna close that up
your day go blue will drop this cuz I
don't need it
yes making good progress hey then I go
back to you and then I can make up my
other cards where did I get a map then I
get a navigator ah who cares black hair
I don't care
right now they may have changed this I
bet I bet the changes so you can't get
better security cards but let's see what
happens all right I remember before it
was just fine that did it cuz you had to
go up one level at a time huh okay and
then we got the med kit here and then
okay we're good I might just like to
play this legitimately if this does not
work I might just go through the game a
level three what is that was it wasn't
it was it
heard some what huh okay I'm just gonna
take this level three and I must try to
play the game totes legit I get
something push me again I swear
something is pushing me it's bull this
bull is a whole lot of bull this pull
someone is sticking with me do not
appreciate ah
hey Tammy what is this oh it's the music
I can't stare at this or else I'll try
to finish it with my own blood I
remember that but there might be
something down here that I need now
didn't do it alright
my dad thought I got buzzing right oh
I'm being bushed
okay alright that's right I forgot okay
no how about no
put the door back up door back up seems
to be locked
it's his so it's so weird I'm like I'll
go into here nope nope nope nope
absolutely not it's on here
what Oh No okay I thought we gave those
okay here's a revised version of the
arrangement
I can't out whatever it's gonna kill me
for - that's stupid and creepy it's like
a haunted Carnival of nightmares fact
this whole place is like a haunted
Carnival of nightmares now that I
mention it I do not like this place do
the like it stop with your horrible
clown music I just imagine a bunch of
Bozo the clown's of spinning around my
head like greenery playing their
accordion reading god damn it shut up
shut up you're in my brain another fan
that's not actually spinning
I guess when the facility wants an app
it kind of shut up what why are you
gonna shake my camera why you shake my
camera
it's just shook my camera for no reason
something is sticking with me I know
something is very much with me
why why why the this what is
this this is new hello are you watching
me son of a you're all watching me
engine ok existing heavy containment
zone heavy containment of what I wasn't
in the heavy containment zone before yes
little 3 son of a fu are there two
doors
let's hope that I never need to come
back there I didn't get my upgraded
gasps Wow whatever I'm an idiot okay
what I got to go through this security
zone just get through here is he in
there is he in there he doesn't look
like he's in there but I it doesn't look
like he's in there but I always I'm
still suspicious saying here we go up
here don't be an enemy
okay always still bear good to be
paranoid late kids out there watching
it's good to be paranoid about these
things because oh crap really really
really you're gonna send me down into
the sewers right away okay
I don't have my upgraded gas mask so I
can't run forever but I can make it I
can make it oh look it's actually light
down there that's bright lights in the
city
oh no they're not they're not that
bright I just used to have my gas mat
gone all the time
Oh what's down here what's down here
this is where who's where their zombie
men were one day I swear there's no no
where their zombie brother don't open
that door
what is that sound Oh 1111 oh wow this
is nothing but a fact what what 7 3
gobby-o down here ah I hate stores so
much the worst sores are the worst oh
here I go back down cuz bar bars do it
alright torturing myself no Matt no is
actually pretty cool oh my god is like
an amalgamation of everyone
decided to conquer it
he's in the sewers Hey that's exactly
what they sound like behind my back Oh
marklar hey better killed hey my
favorite new noise I was love it when I
play a game and I discover a new noise I
can make can completely annoy my
audience okay you're here I know you are
by a bad idea to save down here but
whatever so you come out of that door
don't come out of that door is what I'm
trying to say don't do it
on the way oh that's a dead body where's
one seven three where's one seven three
ones having the right it was here before
oh my god it is dark okay here we go
I made it ah stick to be locked he'll
open loving loving I have faith it's
y'all open ah see what I mean
okay out for the entirety of that store
I hope I never ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
have to go there again
ah no no not right no the other way the
other way I look it's dead body
okay the dead body
wait what did they pick up what what is
that what is this they eat it I feel
better I fell banner I mean I know I'm
wait no no how do I load it quick lod
load beam me up Scotty what I yeah all
right whatever
I'll live with my decision or I'll die
with my decision what the guy quiet
what
hmm what is with the rumbling no no
don't care
long-haired open I probably needed that
scp-500 dashboard don't know why though
oh come on No now let's Paul you can't
do that
who's this of course note I thought this
was only available what what
who's this a I feel better what do I
feel better oh I still have it
wait what what do we still have it so
weird
what's going on I'm so confused but I'm
all out of time so who's gonna lose okay
just
it's been so long since I played this
and added so much new crap okay I guess
I'm done Wow okay this is gonna be
awesome
all right I'm gonna start doing this
regularly again so um if you guys want
to see more parts let me know the
description below thank you all so much
for watching thank you for supporting me
in on all that drunk legendary the
videos but I dig terror really the girl
in a gentleman
that's all but I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh
but
bigger into